[Musik]
die baader bank in hamburg sie gehört zu
den ältesten privatbanken deutschlands
und ist player im größten steuerbetrug
der deutschen nachkriegsgeschichte und
ausgerechnet der heutige bundeskanzler
gerät immer wieder in verdacht in den
skandal verwickelt zu sein das ist jetzt
seit zweieinhalb jahren ein thema
journalisten für alle möglichen die an
dem thema arbeiten auch für den
ausschuss in hamburg es sind unglaublich
viele personen gehört worden sind
unglaublich viele akten studiert werden
und wenn man jetzt die
presseberichterstattung über die
jeweiligen anhörungen anderes verfolgt
dann ist immer das ergebnis es hat keine
beeinflussung durch die politik gegeben
was die entscheidung betrifft
sicher dass diese erkenntnis nicht mehr
verändert werden wird nach zweieinhalb
jahren ist das ganz klar der reihe nach
in den jahren 2001 bis 2011 betrugen
etwa 100 banken darunter auch die
warburg-bank den deutschen staat mit
sogenannten comex geschäften worum ging
es comex geschäfte waren aktiengeschäfte
bei denen anleger einmalig steuern
zahlten sich aber mehrfach die abgaben
erstatten ließen das ging so händler
verschoben untereinander die wertpapiere
und zwar immer rund um den stichtag an
dem dividenden dafür ausgezahlt wurden
einer bekam die dividende dafür wurden
entsprechend steuern einbehalten die
ließ er sich später erstatten durch das
verschachtelte system der comex
geschäfte kassierten aber auch andere
händler eine rückzahlung über jahre
hinweg verlor der fiskus dadurch
milliarden
2012 wurde per gesetz dieses geschäft
verboten die finanzämter fingen an die
fehlenden milliarden bei den banken
zurückzufordern so auch von der
warburg-bank oft mit hilfe der
steuerfahndung die
nordrhein-westfälische steuerfahndung
hat hinweise über einen datenträger das
mehr als 100 banken sich geschäftsmäßig
an comics geschäften beteiligt haben wir
sind jetzt mit den vorermittlungen
soweit das konkret gegen diese banken
vorgegangen werden kann
[Musik]
im januar durchsuchte die
staatsanwaltschaft köln die warburg bank
sie ist zentral für die comex geschäfte
zuständig ihr verdacht besonders schwere
steuerhinterziehung und 170 millionen
euro soll die rabobank mit comics
kassiert haben 1 millionen davon waren
bereits verjährt bei der durchsuchung
franken die bahn mit dabei das tagebuch
des bankchefs christian olearius es
sollte später noch eine zentrale rolle
spielen
[Musik]
es geht um die sogenannten comex
geschäfte der warburg-bank wegen der
mutmaßlich illegalen steuererstattungen
forderte 2016 das finanzamt der
hansestadt einen hohen zweistelligen
millionenbetrag von der bank zurück auch
die staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt warburg
chef christian olearius sah die existenz
der bank gefährdet und suchte kontakt
zur olaf scholz dem damaligen ersten
bürgermeister es kam zu zwei treffen
kurz darauf rückte das finanzamt von
seiner forderung ab er ließ der rabobank
47 millionen euro an steuerschulden
johannes kahrs seinerzeit für die spd im
finanzausschuss des bundestages soll die
treffen von olaf scholz und dem bankchef
mit eingefädelt haben
fakt ist die spd hamburg er hilft 2017
rund 45.000 euro von der warburg-bank
oder von deren tochtergesellschaften als
spende und fakt ist auch 2017 wollte das
hamburger finanzamt erneut der
warburg-bank steuerschulden erlassen
erst eine rigide weisung des
bundesfinanzministeriums die millionen
endlich einzufordern stoppte den plan
der hamburger finanzpartner
im september ließen verschiedene medien
die bombe platzen sie veröffentlichten
auszüge aus den beschlagnahmten tagebuch
des warburger bankchefs diese warfen ein
neues schlaglicht auf olaf scholz der
zentrale verdacht nahm scholz 2016 als
damaliger erster bürgermeister von
hamburg politischen einfluss auf die
entscheidung der dortigen
finanzverwaltung steuerschulden von der
warburg-bank nicht zurück zu verlangen
die indizien dazu waren rätselhaft denn
das tagebuch des bankchefs verrät mehr
treffen mit olaf scholz als dieser
bisher bekannt gegeben hatte
im märz 2020 hatte scholz im
finanzausschuss des bundestages diese
beiden treffen mit bankchef olearius
nicht erwähnt die politik in berlin und
hamburg war alarmiert
gleich drei mal muss sich der
vizekanzler heute erklären morgens im
finanzausschuss zwei stunden dauert die
befragung wir haben uns sehr gut
miteinander unterhalten ich habe mir zur
aufgabe gemacht alle fragen die die
abgeordneten hat diese präzise zu
antworten beantworten und wir noch froh
dass die gelegenheit jetzt endlich
gekommen ist runde zwei und drei im
bundestag scholz bestreitet sich für die
bank eingesetzt zu haben ein händler
bürgermeister ein guter minister ist
jemand der ganz viele gespräche geführt
und in sieben jahren ich habe das nie
gezählt aber gefühlt tausende und es ist
glaube ich sehr plausibel dass man sich
nicht an jedes einzelne dieser gespräch
erinnern kann aber woran man sich eher
kindern kann es wie man isst ich zum
beispiel bin so dass es bei der frage
von entscheidung von finanzämtern keine
politische intervention gibt die frage
ist nicht ob wir uns treffen die frage
ist wie wir innerlich eingestellt sind
und ob wir uns davon beeindrucken lassen
und beeinflussen lassen drei runden
dieselben fragen dieselbe skepsis
natürlich erinnert man sich an jedes
gespräch wenn es aber um viele millionen
euro für die stadt hamburg geht finde
ich das doch
bemerkenswert ihm ging es darum zu
betonen dass er mit der sache nichts zu
tun gehabt habe hat er sich kategorisch
festgelegt und das bleibt für olaf
scholz auch die politische messlatte
scholz kanzlerkandidatur macht die
finanzskandale für die politische
konkurrenz interessant für ihn aber
brisant heute war nur ein auftakt
tatsächlich der zweite akt heute acht
wochen später hamburg setzte einen
parlamentarischen untersuchungsausschuss
rund um den warburg skandal ein
der parlamentarische
untersuchungsausschuss
hat noch mehr mittel wir können zeugen
befragen können sie verteidigen und von
daher wird dann ganz klar sein was sache
war und was nicht und nicht noch
verdächtigungen im raum stehen als ob da
irgendwie was ganz schlimmes gewesen
wäre oder so wir wollen das aufklären
und den menschen in der stadt deutlich
machen was passiert ist die opposition
will vor allem den damaligen
bürgermeister und heutigen
bundesfinanzminister olaf scholz
vorladen außer dem bürgermeister peter
tschentscher der damals finanzsenator
war und ein halbes jahr später zu beginn
des bundestagswahlkampfs
musste olaf scholz im april 21 selbst
vor dem ausschuss rede und antwort
stehen seine treffen mit bankchef
olearius erklären die drängendste frage
ist was geschah im amtszimmer des
bürgermeisters hinter verschlossenen
türen scholz räumte die treffen erst
spät ein nach dem unter anderem das ard
magazin panorama darüber berichtet hatte
an details erinnere er sich aber nicht
eine situation wo eine bank sagt die
zweitgrößte bank in dieser stadt sie
wird vielleicht pleitegehen wenn das
finanzamt die fonds geld einfordert und
daran kann sich herr scholz nicht
erinnern das glaube ich nicht eine
einflussnahme auf die entscheidung der
finanzbehörde streitet scholz auch heute
vor dem ausschuss kategorisch ab die
hamburger spd verteidigt ihren früheren
bürgermeister wer jemandem vorwirft
einfluss genommen zu haben muss dafür
indizien oder beweise vorlegen und bis
heute ist das nicht geschehen die bank
hat ihre steuerschulden aus den comics
geschäften inzwischen vollständig
beglichen will das aber nicht als
schuldanerkenntnis verstanden wissen und
vom bundesgerichtshof bekamen die
staatsanwälte unterdessen bei der suche
nach schuldigen im comic skandal der
warburg-bank schützen helfen der
bundesgerichtshof hat erstmals die
milliarden schweren sogenannten codex
geschäfte für strafbar erklärt die
richter bestätigten die verurteilung
zweier ex börsenhändler sie waren vom
bonner landgericht zu bewährungsstrafen
wegen steuerhinterziehung verurteilt
worden die gewinne aus den geschäften
dürfen laut bgh eingezogen werden die in
den skandal verwickelte private
hamburger warburg bank muss daher 176
millionen euro zahlen bei den comics
geschäften haben sich investoren banken
und aktienhändler steuermilliarden
erstatten lassen die sie nie gezahlt
hatte also dieses heutige urteil des
bundesgerichtshofes ist wirklich ein
scharfes schwert die banken die zittern
jetzt den ihnen drohen hohe
rückzahlungen an den fiskus wobei sie
jetzt wahrscheinlich hoffen werden dass
die mühlen der justiz langsam mahlen
werden aber es ist so rund 1000 weitere
banker und börsenhändler sind allein in
deutschland beschuldigt illegale comex
geschäfte getätigt zu haben der schaden
für die steuerzahler liegt bei
mindestens zehn milliarden euro
europaweit wohl sogar bei bis zu 50
milliarden euro aber eines lässt sich
sagen am heutigen tag comex dürfte für
die banken mit diesem urteil vorbei sein
denn jetzt drohen sowohl den instituten
als auch den einzeltätern hohe geld und
auch haftstrafen
in bonn wurde heute ein ehemaliger
manager der warburg-bank vorteil
urteilsverkündung vor dem bonner
landgericht der ehemalige manager der
hamburger warburg bank bekommt eine
freiheitsstrafe von dreieinhalb jahren
wegen der beteiligung an comics
geschäften der vorsitzende hat hier in
der urteilsbegründung klar gesagt dass
die mitwirkung des angeklagten an den
geschäften hier wesentlich war er mit
anderen worten so der vorsitzende ein
rad im getriebe war bei den comics
geschäften haben banken und andere
investoren aktien so lange hin und her
gehandelt bis die finanzämter nicht mehr
wussten wem sie gehörten dadurch wurden
einmal gezahlte kapitalertragssteuern
mehrfach erstattet ein milliardenschaden
für den staat allein im fall der
geschäfte an denen der angeklagte
beteiligt war sagt der schaden laut
gericht bei mehr als 100 millionen euro
der bank manager hat sich dabei nicht
selbst bereichert als geschäftsführer
einer tochter der hamburger warburg bank
hat er aber fonds aufgelegt die für
comics genutzt worden waren
die warburg bank hat mit ihrem fonds
reichen investoren ermöglicht in comics
zu in das heißt es geht in diesem fall
jetzt weniger darum dass die bank selber
diese geschäfte gemacht hat sondern sie
hat kunden die investition in diese
geschäfte ermöglicht der angeklagte ist
der erste warburg manager der seine
beteiligung an den illegalen geschäften
gestanden hat das hat sich strafmildernd
ausgewirkt die juristische aufarbeitung
des comics skandals steht weiterhin noch
am anfang insgesamt gibt es mehr als
1000 beschuldigte
[Musik]
auch gegen johannes kahrs dem vermittler
der gespräche zwischen olaf scholz von
dem bankchef ermittelt inzwischen die
staatsanwaltschaft fahnder durchsuchten
seine wohnung und nahmen unterlagen mit
der verdacht begünstigung zur
steuerhinterziehung im zusammenhang mit
der warburg-bank und
hamburgs erster bürgermeister peter
tschentscher wurde in seiner funktion
als damaliger finanzsenator vor den
untersuchungsausschuss zitiert
um kurz vor 23 uhr hatte er es hinter
sich bürgermeister peter tschentscher
zeigte sich nach der befragung wie schon
zu deren beginn kämpferisch es ist kein
einziger beleg dafür vorgelegt worden
dass hier eine politische aus
einflussnahme von außen zu gunsten der
warburg-bank erfolgt ist und insofern
setze ich darauf dass der
parlamentarische untersuchungsausschuss
seine arbeit zu ende macht und dann
diese falschen verdächtigung und diese
unterstellung die gegenüber beamten der
hamburger steuerverwaltung formuliert
wurden dann auch endgültig ausgeräumt
sind und das gelte auch für den jetzigen
bundeskanzler selbst die linke die beim
jetzigen bürgermeister und ehemaligen
finanzsenator lange eine direkte
politische einflussnahme zugunsten der
warburg-bank für möglich gehalten hatte
wollte das nach der sitzung nicht mehr
aufrechterhalten
der bürgermeister gesagt es gab keine
direkte einflussnahme davon gehe ich
dann aus dass er sie auch in der form
nicht gemacht hat wir werden das noch
genauer uns ansehen für mich ist die
politische einflussnahme dahin gehen
dass ich befürchte dass er angst hatte
dass die warburg bank aufgrund dessen
pleite geht und diese gefahr für ihn
relativ groß das land und das eher in
die richtung auch durchaus einfluss
genommen hat nicht im store einzelfall
was er deutlich jetzt gesagt hat aber im
allgemeinen bleibt dieses thema da und
mitten in der sommerpause ereilten den
ausschuss neue informationen nun sind
brisante whatsapp nachrichten
aufgetaucht wir haben schon gestern
berichtet und zwar bei der
staatsanwaltschaft in köln die nämlich
ermittelt gegen die finanzbeamtin die
für die warburg bank in hamburg
zuständig war ja so diese sagte
finanzbeamtin hat nach recherchen des
wdr und eine freundin geschrieben ihr
teuflischer plan sei aufgegangen und
zwar kurz nachdem die finanzbehörde 2016
entschieden hat diese gelder in 47
millionen euro höhe nicht
zurückzufordern aus den comics
geschäften und dann fragt die freundin
nach ob man jetzt verlieren lasse das
bejaht die finanzbeamtin wenn nichts
dazwischen komme aber wir kennen eben
nur einen kleinen teil dieser whatsapp
nachricht dort dieser chat verläufe und
wissen eben auch nicht wieder kontext
ist und wie es gemeint ist und dann ist
da noch die sache mit dem schließfach
bei der hausdurchsuchung von johannes
kahrs fanden die mitarbeiter ein
schlüssel vom fach darin rund 415.000
euro in bar woher kam das geld niemand
weiss es auch der kanzler nicht bei der
diesjährigen sommer präsentiert berlin
was wissen sie über das geld fliesst war
von johannes schaden
nichts
nächste frage was glauben sie denn wo es
herkommt keine ahnung von dem sie wissen
dass er als ich
neue indizien neue erkenntnisse der
skandal um die warburg bank wird den
ausschuss in hamburg weiter beschäftigen
[Musik]